?
L'Organisation mondiale de la
santé croit que c'est possible.
Normand Grondin.
- Malgré les millions
de nouvede nouveaux cas de COVIe
jour et les très nombreux décès,
l'Organisation mondiale
de la santé évoque pour
la première fois, et prudemment,
une possible sortie
de crise à l'échelle mondiale.
Selon l'OMS, c'est en Europe,
là où le variant est encore
très actif, qu'on serait
le plus près de voir
la lumière au bout du tunnel.
La principale raison :
le variale variale variant est t
transmissible que d'ici
le mois de mars, il aura
déjà infecté 60 % des Européens.
- À ce rythme-là, disent lesexps
en plus d'une forme d'immunité
collective, imparfaite,
mais fonctionnelle.
Dr CIRIACO PICCIRILLO,
immunologie translationnelle
- Je pense qu'on est en bien
meilleure posture aujourd'hui
qu'on l'était il y a un an,
considérant le déploiement
vaccinal dans la population et
considérant la préexposition
contre le variant Omicron.
- Bien sûr, pour l'instant,
on se trouve toujours
sur le haut de la vague.
En deux mois, on a dénombré
80 millions d'infections dans
le monde, et probablement
beaucoup plus, ce qui équivaut
à 33 nouveaux cas par seconde
et un décès à chaque douze
secondes.
On pourrait aussi devoir
affronter un varia
dangereux. Mais encore là,
celui-ci devra d'abord affronter
le tout-puissant variant
Omicron e répandre.
- Si le prochain variant
qui rentre dans la communauté
n'a pas la même capacité
de se ré l'intérieur
d'un individu et de se propager
d'un individu à l'autre, il est
en compétition à la course
si vous voulez contre Omicron.
- Pour parvenir à juguler
, il faudra protéger
au moins 70 % de la population
mondiale d'ici la fin
de l'année, dit l'OMS.